for the night is dark and full of
terrors hey youtubers it's Charlie so
this week I thought it'd be really fun
to talk about all the classes of magic
on a game of Thrones the show hasn't
really gone in too deeply to explain a
lot of them but I thought it'd be really
fun to explore even though the show
hasn't really explained them a lot we've
seen everything from the red God to the
drowned God to the Seven to the great
other magic is might careful for
spoilers one of the really cool things
about the gods on Game of Thrones is
that no matter how obscure they are they
do bestow some sort of power one of the
really good examples of this is when
Melisandre gives birth to the smoked
baby with sir Davos underneath storms
end let's explain during season 2 when
Melisandre wants to unleash this smoked
baby on Renly she has to pass inside the
walls of storms end obviously she goes
underneath with sir Davos but because
the seven protect Renly in this camp
while he's within the walls of storms
end her magic can't affect him not only
is this big because of the big WTF smoke
baby moment it's also a good example
that the seven actually do have a real
power that stop her God from exerting
his own influence one of the really
common things about the gods on Game of
Thrones is that it's not really clear if
their power is totally dependent upon
faith or prayer I like to think of that
as Neil Gaiman American Gods logic and
what that means is is that in his novel
American Gods all of the deities have a
direct relationship between their power
and the prayer they received from
followers or even random people I'll
actually be talking about that series
more in other videos later this year
just because HBO is actually turning it
into the next a Song of Ice and Fire but
now let's talk about each of the major
deities on a game of Thrones starting
with the old gods because there might be
some spoilers for bran during the old
gods talk because they exist in this
relationship with the three-eyed crow
and green seers I'll include a spoiler
warning and then at the end of it I'll
include an unmute on the screen so you
can unmute the screen in case you don't
want to hear that part so get ready for
old gods and spoilers now so the old
gods are actually like gods of nature of
the forest trees animals natural things
they're called the old gods because the
Andals when they invaded Westeros
actually brought the seven as religion
just like Christianity the only people
currently practicing the religion in
Westeros or the blackfish the starts and
the people in the north and everything
beyond the wall oh she actually says
that the only gods beyond the wall are
the old gods although technically they
don't have any priests the old gods most
obvious physical manifestation on the
world of A Song of Ice and Fire are the
white weirwood trees or the heart raises
that are called
they exist in almost all the castles of
Westeros and they exist beyond the wall
and mass the children of the forest also
carve faces into them so they each have
these red looking eyes just because of
their bark the actual closest thing that
the old gods have to priests are the
green seers as of A Song of Ice and Fire
there's only one green seer that we know
is alive we haven't met him on the show
yet a brain is actually travelling to
meet him and learn about the three I
crow so the green satyrs do have a few
specific powers they can actually
commune with anything in nature that's
alive by choice that means that they can
warg into anything that's alive anywhere
on the earth it's implied though that
they mostly associate this power with
the weirwood trees so anywhere that
there's a weirwood tree they can
actually see if you remember when
someone wards into someone else it's
actually like gaining access to their
hard drive of memories so you can almost
see across that our entire lifespan in
an instant
so effectively because the weirwood
trees are actually some of the oldest
living things on Westeros anywhere
there's a weirwood tree the green cedars
have the ability to travel back in time
and see events surrounding that tree or
at least the directions that that face
that's carved on it is looking time
travel high fives you can also turn the
volume back up long in flash so next up
is the seventh they actually supplanted
the old gods whenever the Andals came to
Westeros you can think of them as being
a lot like Christianity because it's
technically just one God with many
aspects to the seven just like
Christianity came from the east and the
Seven aspects actually are the father
the mother the warrior the maiden the
Smith the Crone and the stranger and
because the stranger actually represents
death Ari ends up crossing paths with
him later in the series I don't want to
give too much away because it involves
the faceless ones and her Pagar McGillis
coin and going to Braavos
Vimal Kunis so a lot like Christianity
the seven actually have a Bible called
the seven pointed star they have a
religious order and one of the really
funny things is that the religion
actually ends up coming to bite a lot of
really mean evil characters in King's
Landing in the ass later in the series
next up is the drowned
he was worshipped in the Iron Islands
when the Andals invaded Westeros and the
Andals that actually invaded the Iron
Islands instead of converting them to
the seven just decided to adopt the
local religion which was the drowned God
their followers don't have any specific
powers other than their consecration
actually involves literally being
drowned and brought back to life these
dangers may never die what is dead may
never die the next step is the
many-faced God it's technically just
meta kind of offshoot of one of the
aspects of the 7 so you see things start
to get a little bit meta in a game of
Thrones where religions start to
influence each other just like
Lutheran's and Christianity and
Methodists and all these different
options of Christianity though the
many-faced God actually has his own
aspects but he's mostly worshiped by the
faceless once the order of assassins
that is going to tie in with one of the
characters on a game of Thrones later
though think of the followers of the
many-faced God as the assassins like
Jack and Hagar that we met on season 2
and if you remember when you saw him
change his face I actually believe that
a portion of that is just a learned
skill and another portion of that is a
supernatural quality granted to them
deccan doesn't fully explain it to re on
the show but for them death is actually
a gift that they give people it's not
murder done out of revenge it's actually
something that they offer people as a
mercy so this sounds a little weird
there's actually a lot of all these
different gods that have all these
different faces that share a lot of
qualities so let me know if you think
that a lot of them are actually just the
same God that's interpreted in different
ways personally I think that they
actually are separate gods just because
a lot of their powers are a little bit
separate but wouldn't it be the most
awesome mindfuck if they were all just
the same God with just many different
faces Game of Thrones DaVinci Code
somebody solve it high fives so moving
on to the red God and the great other so
george RR martin actually explains that
these two gods actually exist in this
duality whereby the red god represents
illumination and the great other
represents death and destruction
based on what Melisandre has said on the
show and what george RR martin has
explained in the books
the conflict between roller and the
great other will only end when azor Ahai
rises out of the flames with his flaming
Lightbringer sword on a stone dragon if
you remember that tied into gantry being
sacrificed supposedly they were trying
to raise that stone dragon at the end of
season three big woods no claims would
use them
Melisandre actually thinks of Stannis as
azor Ahai and she even calls that sword
that he has in season 2 light bringer
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
him a lot of people think that maybe
John Snow might get resurrected as a
Zora hi or some other character but let
me know what you think some of the
powers that the priests of the red God
like Thoreau's and Melisandre have our
measure of Resurrection using the gift
of life they also have a measure of
vision by looking into flames but it's
subject to their interpretation so there
is a certain margin for error and I'll
explain a really good example of that
Melisandre actually sees something in
the flames that she interprets as the
champions of the great other but
technically in my opinion I think she's
all just seeing the same person what she
says she sees are as a wooden face
corpse white a thousand red eyes and a
boy with a wolf's head standing beside
him in reality I think she's just
talking about bran after
he's learned more about his greenseer
powers so she's seeing those white faces
of the weirwood trees which actually
have red eyes and think of it you know
dire wolf standing next to him wolf said
so you get the idea well let me know in
the comments if you think that bran is
actually going to become the champion of
the great other personally I don't think
he is just because nature exists is this
really neutral idea it just exists to
serve all living things so technically
even though the great other represents
death you could say that he represents
good but it's really open to
interpretation and let me know what you
think as events on the show unfold all
start talking more specifically about
each of the gods as they exist in
certain episodes or exert influence like
when Melisandre has scenes but send me
your questions about specific things
I'll try to include them in a future
video I'll be doing another Game of
Thrones video real soon so send me
suggestions and I'll try to include them
so also big news I just hit 5,000
subscribers so I made a thank you video
for all you guys you can click here I'll
be posting it later today or you can
click here to watch my first korra
season 2 video thanks for watching high
fives for magic
you